hey guys here's a quick video on how to
get a little extended task manager uh
which is a um basically a replacement
for the built-in control shift escape
uh built-in task manager for windows
vista i'm running vista right now um
so here's what it is and how to get it
um
uh
open up an internet browser and i'll
post this link in your description so
i'm going to copy and paste that right
now
this links is an extended task manager
which gives you a much much much broader
system overview view
gives you
a whole lot about your memory uses your
disk reading and writing history
cpu history for a longer period of time
networking your port usage
um and even a summary tab for a whole
lot of this um this is your port usage
uh so it's it's really really nice all
the features that they give you
and if you do want it um the link i give
you is this website all you have to do
is scroll down
and open this window and open it in a
new tab and that'll bring up this
one
and you just click on the free download
and it'll replace the control shift
escape
this task manager it'll it'll replace
this one you'll well you will have it if
you uninstall it but if you hit ctrl
shift escape again which is your
shortcut for vista task manager
or if you're in xp it is control alt
delete
then
this will be replaced by the extended
task manager which is good it's good
that they integrated that in so you no
longer have to search
and look for it every time you want to
use it
so this is just a brief tutorial i hope
i can get it up in hd
um
i think it's a neat little freeware
program i'll start reviewing freeware i
found a website called
i don't even know but it's got a whole
lot it's freeware freewaregenius.com
i'll post that one too
um
a whole lot of
freeware cool software people might want
to look into
um
so yes that's what this video is about
if you want to go ahead and subscribe
it's that orange button on the left hand
side
um
yeah you're going to want to do that
more videos to come guys peace out